The story at the heart of
Gucci is extraordinary.
There are a lot of rumors around.
It has got passions,
it's got family, it's got feuding.
It's got loves and loathing and tragedy,
even murder.
It's better to cry in Rolls-Royce
than to be happy on a bicycle.
That story is really the
appeal and the excitement
and yes, the sex factor
of a brand like Gucci.
Sometimes things happen in
life that change your life.
This was really success
beyond my wildest imagination.
I didn't believe possible,
Tom did not believe it was possible.
The success was unbelievable.
It is difficult to understate
just how successful the Gucci brand
has been in history,
but also really is right now.
We're looking at a brand value
of something like $15 billion
and that's underpinned by an extraordinary
social media following.
So you both got this business value
and also you've got this
dynamism in the digital world.
That combination has really been the key
to Gucci's success.
There's been an unfairness
to give a lot of credit to people
who really didn't deserve all that credit.
And instead people who had deserved credit
were totally forgotten.
Nobody has focused on the real story.
Everybody has focused on the fairy tale.
That's very good news for the viewers
and maybe also for the media
but it's not the reality.
There is an epic saying
in Italy when it comes to
family generations that the
first generation creates,
the second generation expands,
and the third generation destroys.
And that's almost what happened
in the Gucci story.
You've got the founder
who was Guccio Gucci
who had the vision for
making quality leather goods
and selling them initially
to American tourists
and other European travelers.
And then you have his two
sons, Rodolfo and Aldo,
who ended up having
each 50% of the company.
And especially Aldo
was really the marketer
and the expander,
and he had a vision to take
Gucci outside of Italy.
And then you have the third generation
which is also where a lot
of the conflicts started
because you had Aldo's three sons,
Roberto, Georgio, and Paolo,
and they had 50% together
with their father.
And then you have Maurizio
on the other side,
a single child who inherited
50% from his father Rodolfo.
The Gucci story was really punctuated
by the family conflicts
and they were extremely litigious.
So, all of these fights
spilled out into open court
and became extremely public.
One of the characters that
really had the longest arc
and almost the most
knowledge about the story
was Domenico De Sole
who started as a lawyer to
Rodolfo in the early '80s.
So, hi, Domenico.
Hi. How are you?
So what was it like working for Rodolfo
and then dealing with Aldo
and the family?
It was very complicated
because that point what was happening
there was a big conflict in the family
because Aldo's children probably felt
that their dad had done
such a phenomenal job,
which is true.
Aldo was a pretty formidable person
but they felt that they deserve
more than the 1/4 of 50%.
So we had a lot of battle
that went on and on
for a long time.
But then the situation
was basically confirmed
and there was no change in
the shareholder ownership,
and Maurizio kept the 50%.
And that was the situation
but that created a lot of animosity,
there where a lot of battle.
He dreams every five minutes.
He doesn't think, he dreams.
And in his own life, he'd
still run as a child.
Today, we do $138 million of business
with $18 million profit.
This is the answer to a dream.
I accept.
So major turning point
in this family story
was 1983 Rodolfo is very ill and he dies,
and he leaves his 50% stake in the company
to his only son Maurizio.
Maurizio is starting to get
his ideas even back then
about how he wants to
clean up the Gucci brand
and take it up market,
but he can't get his uncle
and his cousins on board.
They're very happy with all of
the lucrative licensing deals
that are very profitable for them.
So as Maurizio is becoming
more and more convinced
of his vision for Gucci,
and that he's the one who
needs to take it forward,
on the home front he's also
falling out with his wife
Patrizia who had been pushing him
to be the kind of Mr. Gucci
and one of the leading
luxury CEOs in Milan.
But he's starting to
feel a little bit pressed
and in 1985, he decides to leave her.
We have this transformation.
Mr. Jekyll became Dr. Hyde.
The same time you had Paolo
ratting on his father, Aldo,
to the US tax authorities
because he suspected his
father of siphoning off profits
and putting them into offshore accounts.
So, there was a case
then started by the IRS,
an investigation that ended
up sending Aldo to jail.
I never forget.
I remember we had a board
meeting of Gucci America
and Maurizio asked me, and said,
"You have to explain what this means."
And yes, I tried to explain
to the members of family,
this is the United
States, it's very serious.
On tax fraud is very
serious, it's not Italy.
One member of the board said to me,
"You are pessimistic."
I said, "Oh, maybe.
I don't know what you want me to say."
Unfortunately, Aldo did go to jail
and at that point,
again, it's a big change in my life
because I went from being the lawyer
for the company and the family.
He asked me to run Gucci America
and with a specific goal
of settling with the IRS.
The reputation was still
at a very good reputation.
Most importantly
worldwide name recognition
because Aldo, they're
awfully really geniuses.
They open store in places like Japan
in Hong Kong, in Asia,
you know the really amazing early
on they were in all these markets.
But there was a problem,
I think the product was really getting
to be less attractive.
They also expanded
distribution dramatically.
So there were a lot of events that occur
that really the brand was deteriorating.
There are many lessons
from luxury brand history
about the balance between
brand value and revenue growth
because frankly it can be
easy to get overexcited
about the possibility of revenue growth,
increased distribution,
and of course, Gucci
have had their own issues
and challenges on losing
control of the brand experience
in and out of their history.
There have been times when
they have over-expanded,
they lost control of product quality
in their drive for international success.
What is it that makes the brand valuable?
It will often be exclusivity.
It'll be the control of
the customer experience
that people can feel confident
about what they're gonna
get in product terms,
what they're gonna get in service terms,
and also the authenticity
that they're going to get
is part of what they're buying.
And so therefore you need to make sure
you are feeding that brand value
or what it is that
makes the brand valuable
in the first place.
So Maurizio had a problem
because he had a clear vision for Gucci
but he didn't have the money
to buy out his relatives.
The answer to his problem
was an investment banker
who worked for Morgan Stanley at the time
named Andrea Morante.
I can remember very vividly
as if it were yesterday
that when I explained to the
other partners in the room
the Morgan Stanley room
that I had met with Maurizio Gucci
and that he wanted to do
some form of shareholding restructuring,
I'll never forget that for the first time
when I was describing a transaction
everybody was interested.
And that's, if you will,
the first time that I understood
the power of a brand.
So he launches this plan
at a stealth campaign
with Morgan Stanley to buy up the shares
of Aldo and his cousins,
and bring in an investment
bank, Investcorp
as his financial partner.
'Cause he didn't have enough money
to just buy it all himself.
As far as the complexity of purchasing
the cousins and also the uncle,
well, that complexity had one solution
which you could call
today inside information.
Because I spent a lot
of time with Maurizio,
he gave me all the inside information
of what everybody within the family,
really what the agenda was.
And in particular, he
also explained to me how
Paolo Gucci had been
ill-treated by his father
and given a significant
reduced number of shares
vis-a-vis his brothers
because Paolo had literally
took his father to jail.
So what I did is I proposed to him
to be paid a very similar amount of money
as if he had not been
penalized by his father.
I'll pay you the same price
that your brothers are
going to be receiving.
He accepted.
So I actually went there
with a suitcase of cash
and purchased this initial
3% from Paolo Gucci
which actually changed the life of Gucci.
[Interviewer] One person
who worked for the company
said Paolo has been a traitor to everyone.
Yes. Maybe.
Yes.
Again, these bandits,
I mean, if you leave them
then you're a traitor, right?
Once they saw that the game was over
and there was somebody else coming
to actually run the business,
then gradually one by one,
they all sold their shares.
So what initially was
almost a mission impossible
turned into a reality.
50% of all the available shares
were ultimately purchased by Investcorp,
and at that stage, Investcorp
and Maurizio had the company.
So Maurizio emerges as
the CEO, he had control
because even though he
was in a 50/50 agreement
with Investcorp, they gave
him management control.
His vision was to take
Gucci back up market
and that meant quality products,
beautiful workmanship.
And he had a very classic idea
of what he wanted Gucci to be.
He used to say he wanted
to be round and brown
and soft to a woman's hand.
He opened this fabulous
headquarters in Milan,
no expense spared,
priceless antiques,
workmanship.
So the debt started racking
up really, really fast
and at the same time he had cut out
the most lucrative parts of the business.
So, the Gucci accessories collection
which was the cash cow for the company.
Things were done in a
somewhat irrational way.
I think that he incurred
massive costs in Italy
which the company could
not afford at the time.
He decided we had to
clean an old new product.
Okay, well, that's a great idea
but what is the cost of it?
So overnight he said, no more GG.
So I said, "Well, Maurizio,
GG is like 70% of the sales."
But he wanted to do it all costs
so the company really went to tailspin
and started really losing money,
and was very, very difficult.
Became very painful.
So, the situation became
dire with Gucci's finances.
They were not able to pay salaries.
They were not able to pay suppliers.
They were on the verge of having
to take the company's books
into court to say they
couldn't settle the accounts.
And at that point,
that means that the company
has declared bankruptcy.
So, Gucci is really teetering
on the brink at this stage.
He had to right these things.
I think that the problem
he couldn't make it happen.
There's some people have great vision
but he had the greatest
vision, the great strategy
but if you execute he was
beyond incapable of executing.
That really was the bottom line.
So Investcorp after
giving Maurizio free reign
to put his vision into place,
they're becoming very, very
worried about the situation,
and they are millions
of dollars in the hole.
And they're deciding they don't
wanna put any more money in
because they think it's
just going down the drain.
I told him that it was
in his best interest
in order to keep and preserve
the good relationship he
had had with Investcorp
to go to Investcorp and say
let's choose a common new
chief executive officer,
somebody who's really
gonna operate the business.
And so, when I told him that
unfortunately the reaction
was extremely negative
because for him, I was telling
him, which is the truth,
that he was not capable
to run the company.
And I felt the responsibility
of telling him that
in his own interest
but sometimes your own interest
is perceived in a different way.
He is begging them for time.
His assessment is that the turnaround
needs a little more time for the customers
to really get the feeling
for how Gucci's changed.
And at one point he's begging them,
"If you just give me six months," he says,
"the Japanese market is
going to realize that
there's a new Gucci
and the wind will be back in our sales."
Well, he never got that chance.
Investcorp created a war room.
They went after him with
everything they could
and finally they were
successful in kicking him out,
and they bought his 50% in
the company for $150 million
and then took it over entirely.
The irony of this story was that actually
Maurizio was right.
Six months after he was
forced out by Investcorp,
the Japanese woke up to the new Gucci
and started buying Gucci bags,
and the company started making money,
hand over fist in a very quick time.
In March of 1995, one
morning, broad daylight
Maurizio is walking into the
front door of his new offices,
a gunman comes into the doorway behind him
and shoots him dead in cold blood.
The murder of Maurizio Gucci
was a shocking event for the city
and in addition to being shocking,
it was very sinister because
there was no clear culprit.
The prosecutor who was
investigating the case
was looking into his business deals,
he was looking into the family conflicts.
He interviewed the cousins,
he interviewed Patrizia
but he didn't really see
a clear family connection.
And the case was just cold after two years
until because of a tipster one day,
one morning at 5:30 in the morning
the police raid Patrizia's
apartment on Corso Venezia
and arrest her for Maurizio's murder.
She had an obsession.
She wanted her husband dead
and she spoke about it to everyone.
Often people are remembered
for the wrong reasons
and the glamor and maybe the interest
has more to do with the homicide.
A wife appoints a killer, a hitman
and perhaps there is a risk
that Maurizio will indeed
be remembered as somebody
who was killed by his
wife for no reason at all,
or for very good reasons
depending on where you sit.
But I think that Maurizio's real legacy
is that the Gucci brand
has really been created
by three generations.
As often as the case in
some family businesses,
after the third generation,
the family is not able to
keep control of the company.
In this case, Maurizio not only
lost control of the company
but he also lost his life.
In the early stages of many luxury brands,
the founder, the visionary,
the original creative director,
they came almost to the
end of their tenure,
and they needed somebody
else to take the brand on
in a different direction
or a fresh direction.
I think you could also
say, with the Gucci brand,
that's a hundred years old,
over time, a brand like that
needs to have fresh input,
and fresh eyes.
So even though Maurizio wasn't ultimately
successful in putting his vision in place,
he had actually done a lot of the work
to set Gucci up for it's next phase.
He hired an American retail
executive, Dawn Mello,
who was the president of
Bergdorf Goodman, at the time,
and one of her main contributions
was to hire, Tom Ford.
After Maurizio left,
they started giving me more
and more responsibility,
and I became the Chief Operating Officer
of the company very quickly.
And at that point, I really,
de facto, I was running a company,
they basically asked me who I thought to
be the Creative Director,
and I felt very strongly to be Tom.
I remember very vividly,
I drove up to Milan,
and Tom was very, very young.
We had a meeting and I said Tom,
I think we can really fix this company.
So, I said look,
I'm not interested in
interfering, I'm a businessman.
I don't pretend to be a
creative person by any means,
so you're in charge, you know, you do it,
and let's see where we go here.
He accepted and that's really
the beginning of the story.
He bought back the logo,
and make it chic.
He makes clothes that rock the world,
and he put sex back where it belongs.
Here's Tom Ford for Gucci.
Thank you. I'd like to thank Vogue.
Tom, you're the greatest!
Thank You!
Thank you.
It's difficult to understate the impact of
Tom Ford on Gucci.
No, it's not just about fashion,
has purchased 5% of the company.
it's also about real life.
With his extraordinary style, innovation,
and actually his sense of control,
this is one of the really
really key success criteria.
There has to be a vision,
and it has to be a very direct vision.
Tom Ford has a very, very clear,
and strong idea about what Gucci could be,
in terms of global ambition.
He made sure that his vision
was totally controlled right
across the customer experience.
From the advertising, every
point of communication,
product detail, and so on.
Ford's design power hit the fashion world
like a tidal wave.
The winner is,
And the winner is
Tom Ford.
Thank you, thanks.
So, the "Tom-Dom" era of Gucci
really was extraordinarily exciting,
and it was clear from the
very first menswear show,
actually, that Tom designed in Florence,
that something had changed at Gucci,
and there was a new Gucci in the air.
And sales took off immediately,
and even though they
were showing, kind of,
more sexy styles on the runway,
they were still selling primarily
black and brown handbags,
but they really had lit
a fire under this brand,
and the sales are doubling.
So the sales went through the roof.
In 1995, our sales doubled.
The success was just unbelievable.
Suddenly, really things looked up,
and then at that point
Investcorp wanted to go public
as fast as possible.
So, the Gucci IPO was very anticipated,
but, what they realized was that,
there was no fashion sector
in the financial market,
so they actually had to train analysts in
how the luxury market worked, and so,
Domenico's being given
presentation workshops, and skills.
They are bringing analysts into the room,
and talking about how the industry works.
They really pioneered the luxury sector
in the financial market.
And other brands subsequently followed.
But, it was really the Gucci
IPO that set the stage.
The old Gucci name sure is attracting
a lot of customers these
days, on Main St. and Wall St.
The IPO of Gucci was even more successful
than their wildest dreams.
They debuted at 22 dollars,
and shot immediately up to 26 dollars.
The offering was 14 times over subscribed,
and ended up making more
than 2 billion dollars
for Investcorp.
Sales were up 113%, so we were delighted,
it was the fifth quarter in a row
with which we double our sale.
It proved to be a success story,
certainly from a financial
perspective, for Investcorp.
But also a huge success
story, within the industry.
Once it was clear that the luxury markets
was there to be developed,
and was there to be taken advantage of,
all the players who were
already in that market
had the competitive advantage
of having seen it from within.
The risk was that somebody
could take it over,
and given this massive success.
And it doesn't matter
how successful we are,
we're a public company.
There is always moment, in
which the stock may go down.
In 1997, Gucci was a
high performance machine,
but a financial crisis
hit Asia, putting Gucci,
and the rest of the luxury
goods market in peril.
Japan was the dominant force
in the luxury market at the time.
So, when there was this crisis in Asia,
the stock went down.
And I think at that point was LVMH
started purchasing shares of the company.
That really was my concern
about the possibility
of it being open to a takeover.
So, the real sort of rival on the
market for Gucci was
LVMH and Bernard Arnault,
who was kind of known
as a corporate raider
in the European luxury scene.
He had taken over Louis
Vuitton, Moet Hennessy,
and had other fashion brands, he had Dior.
We tried to build a large business
with our partners with one
criteria, the best quality,
and the most elitist product,
in every line that we are
selling throughout the world.
I got a call from Yves Carcelle,
who is the CEO of Louis Vuitton,
and he called me, told me that LVMH
And at that time if you
went above the 5% threshold,
under the rule of the
New York Stock Exchange,
you had to go public with it.
So, that was really the
beginning of the battle
with LVMH.
And didn't he say something about
how it was a friendly acquisition?
Yeah, he say it was very very friendly.
He say, well you know
Arnault, Mr. Arnault,
has a hell of a reputation,
so I'm not sure how
friendly this is gonna be.
Now were gonna mix a little
money with a lot of style.
From January through
June, two retail titans
battle for control of
fashion's biggest prize,
the House of Gucci.
So, once Arnault had thrown down
the gauntlet for Gucci,
Domenico De Sole realized
that he was in for a big fight,
and he pulled in bankers and advisors,
and decided to stage a resistance,
and his main concern was
that he didn't want Arnault
to be able to take over
control of the company
without offering a full and
fair offer to all shareholders.
They are our number one competitor.
We compete against them for customers.
We compete for talented people.
This is a case of creeping control.
They would like to control the company
without paying the full price.
The contest between these two companies
was getting more and more acrimonious,
and with the help of his advisors,
De Sole put protection
mechanism into place
through the issuing of employee shares,
and that kept on diluting Arnault's stake,
as he's building up his
stake in the company.
But at at certain point, De Sole realizes,
that they aren't going to be able to
fend off Arnault forever.
So, kind of in the ninth
hour, Francois Pinault,
who runs PPR, which was
a French retail group,
comes in and offers to
buy a stake in Gucci,
and becomes the white knight
to help them fight off Arnault.
Francois was the most decisive man
in the history of the universe.
I talked to him for half an hour,
I told my story and I explained
why we wanted to defend against Arnault.
De Sole drove a hard bargain,
securing 3 billion for
Gucci's immediate growth.
It was the very deal
Bernard Arnault rejected.
So Francois Pinault does not only
want to be the white knight,
but he has an even bigger idea,
and so, he turns Yves Saint
Laurent, 3 billion dollars
over to Tom and Dom, and he says,
I want you, kind of, the
dream team of fashion,
to buy up other brands,
and turn Gucci into a multi brand group,
that can rival Arnault and LVMH.
That was pretty brutal because,
we were under pressure to do it, okay.
So it was just a lot of work.
There were a lot of potential targets,
and every time we tried to buy something,
all of a sudden, LVMH would show up.
It was not an easy thing to do,
so everything had to be
done in great secrecy.
It was a huge amount of pressure,
because it was on one
end running the company,
and on the other end
acquiring all these companies,
and we acquired a lot
of companies very fast.
To not only turn around Gucci,
or keep the Gucci turn around going,
but to also then identify other talent,
other brands, make them successful,
I mean, it became a huge endeavor.
They were both working 24/7.
Tom was designing both Gucci
and Yves Saint Laurent,
and at the same time, they
were trying to identify,
and then nurture these other designers.
I was looking for major investment,
and then Gucci got in touch
and the rest is history.
They bought Alexander McQueen.
They bought Stella McCartney.
They bought Balenciaga.
Each brand was slightly different,
you know, some were young
designers that needed
sort of, the help to grow and to mature.
Others were faded names that
needed to be turned around.
So they had a lot of children
that they were trying to
raise, in this endeavor.
There was the agreement that we would
run the company independently for 5 years,
create this multi brand company,
this large group of companies,
and then he would buy 100% of the share,
at the price that had been set forth,
at the time of the battle with LVMH.
So, five years after the
initial white knight, Pinault,
buys the full 100% of Gucci,
and, you know, Tom and
Dom are in a situation,
where they are essentially running this
publicly traded company as
though it were their own.
Until a time comes where
Pinault is taking control,
and it's time to renegotiate the contracts
for Tom and Domenico,
and, they realized that
they aren't going to
have the freedom to run
Gucci, they way they had been,
and Tom and Dom announced
that they were resigning from Gucci.
Which is kind of a shock to
the industry, at that time.
So at the end, Tom was
clear, he was not gonna stay,
and I worked with him
so closely, you know,
was just like my younger brother,
so at the end, we felt, and I felt,
that we had done our part,
and it was time to move on with life.
The partnership between Tom and Domenico
really became foundational.
Not only for the Gucci business,
but for other luxury houses,
that were starting to replicate
the synergy between the
creative and the management.
It became seen as kind of
the essential component
that you needed in that period to run
a successful luxury brand.
Gucci is my legacy, so I love the company,
and I'm super happy about Gucci.
Some people ask me this question, a lot.
No, I always wanted Gucci to do well.
You know, I think it would
have been catastrophic
if Gucci didn't do well
after Tom and I left.
The genius, in many ways, of Gucci,
is how it's been able to reinvent itself,
and also frankly, reinvent
the sex of its times.
If we think about how Gucci
was rescued in the 1990s,
sex sells and that
contemporary view on sex
was a fundamentally
important part of that.
Now we've seen Gucci
really go ahead again.
The last few years have been
phenomenally successful.
Now why is that?
Well, actually, they've expressed sex
in a rather different way.
A gender blending sex, a
non-binary type of sex,
that has really really
resonated with millennials,
and consumers under the age of 35,
and that has been both very unusual,
it's been very challenging
for luxury brands,
but, of course, Gucci have
made it a truly runaway,
and runway success.